you
[Music]
my name is Dirk Umbra here I'm a product
manager at LinkedIn and at LinkedIn for
about 18 months now and like Lauren
mentioned I was running my own startup
which was trying to do more kind of
predictive search in whatever enterprise
settings learned a lot of stuff
completed in progress as fast as we
would have liked but but lots of
learning there was kind of introduction
into data products in general and it
kind of forced me to go out of my
engineering comfort zone and build with
sales because as a start-up founder you
gotta go sell and that was kind of a
segue into my role here at LinkedIn
where they needed somebody who
understands not just a technology and
the product but also can talk to sales
and really understand who these people
are and and build the right stuff for
them so that's briefly my background
from talk perspective I'll spend
literally kind of 30 seconds on the
organizational part what what
organization I'm part of at LinkedIn and
people here have worked in sales or
quick show of hands work with sales
organizations worked on products around
sales or okay few so I'll spend maybe
kind of five minutes or so just got to
set up the primer and not so much in
terms of what sales is I think we sort
of know what it is but what are the
opportunities what are the key
challenges and that we kind of motivate
the rest of the talk here and then we'll
jump right into the the product
perspective if you wanted to build an
intelligent product based on data that
serves the set of users how would you go
about that journey so we spend majority
of the time on that so let's get going
briefly about the organization that I am
part of its a data product organizations
and our job is to bring data to life and
we work at number of layers at the
bottom most layer we are responsible for
the standardization and knowledge graph
and this is critical to every asset that
LinkedIn bills right so a very simple
example would be software engineer
developer three different way or ten
different ways of specifying exact same
job how does LinkedIn figure out that
this is the same thing and and make sure
they use it in the in the product
so that some of the standardization
stuff we do there is also a whole bunch
of effort in terms of reporting search
and discovery of matrix standardization
of matrix targeting ramping
experimentation a/b testing and so on
roughly it kind of falls into two big
buckets initially we try to go after her
internal employees and internal
employees could be developers or in my
case its sales organization but we try
to push the envelope and see if our
members LinkedIn members and customers
can benefit us from some of this as well
so that's roughly the area where we are
looking at very smart for a set of
people we are always hiring so if you're
looking for a pouch that is happy to
talk with that preamble let's jump into
sales so very briefly so what is sales
at the end of the day it's a funnel
there is a top end of the funnel and the
bottom end of the funnel the top in the
funnel is where you as a sales rep
beginning of the quarter or the
beginning of the financial year you
would get a sign whole bunch of accounts
let's say let's pick a number 500
accounts and you have to at the end of
your period of let's say a quarter you
have to deliver a certain amount of
revenue to the company in that's called
quota right and each of this week all
leads are completely unqualified at that
point people may have come to your
website maybe just out of curiosity some
people might have come to your website
because they have a specific problem and
they are looking for solutions or some
of them might have real-time urgency
that hey I know I have a problem I need
to solve it and I have a budget to solve
it now so on that spectrum you can kind
of look at it as a the top end of end of
the funnel is the blue dots which is
lots of unqualified opportunities that
might turn into business somewhere in
between is is is yellow that yeah I
think that problem is there is
validation there we are looking for
solution but not quite sure is it this
quarter or next quarter odd maybe never
and the finally the red dots these are
your hot leads these are your warm leads
and these are very likely are the
customers who would translate into
dollars
so that's what the funnel looks like and
you as a sales rep your job is to
convert as many blue dots into red dots
as fast as you can and it's not just a
job for them it's actually money because
they're all driven by quota if you don't
meet that quota you don't get paid and
I'm slightly exaggerating here but but
majority of their compensation relies on
quota so it's imperative that they
convert this opportunities into into
dollars that's the life of a salesperson
pretty hard life I like I said I've gone
through that myself and did a pretty
horrible job at it so but but if that
there lies the opportunity right so if
you look at the industry benchmark
numbers they're abysmal
it's about five to ten percent of these
blue dots convert into red really really
small conversion rate the DS take a
really long time because again you are
given hundred accounts and now you have
to build those relationships and get
somebody to write a check and that's not
an easy job and and then the numbers
reflect that and the side effect of that
is really only 1/3 of the sales reps
actually end up meeting that quota and
if you kind of to take a 2 year or 3
year boundary it's even a smaller number
so there is lot of odd they're in very
little science and if we kind of now
formalize this what is this inefficiency
right so they're their lies equations
it's the it's one of the big metric true
not metric for sales and it's causes
velocity and it's essentially the same
thing number of leads so you maximize
the blue dots the conversion rate bring
as many as translate as many of blue
dots into red and finally the dollar per
teal and then over the period of time
which is the which is the average length
of the sales cycle that's the metric we
would like to optimize and if you can
optimize that if you can do a better job
compared to the status quo you have an
opportunity and the question for us is
can a data product help here that's
that's a key opportunity that we are
after
so now let's kind of walk through this
product how would this look like how
would you how would you think through
this and like any product manager they
love the term journey so I'm going to go
through a journey and it's a it's a
three-step process
the first one is empathy and now this is
the favorite term of a designer but but
you always start to start with the very
basic principles who are the users who
am i serving what specific is a problem
statement does it even worth solving
there are tons of problems out there is
it a beginner problem that needs solving
and are we in the unique position to
solve that problem versus somebody else
could be solving that so those are the
basics that's kind of a rough fliest
product strategy once you've kind of
figured that out and you figured out the
opportunity part of it the second step
is can I build this product in a manner
that users actually use it and benefit
from it and get consistent value that's
the whole implementation the operational
part of the product and then finally and
that's roughly in the kind of a start-up
um it's a product market fit you build
something you validated that with your
only set of customers they you deliver
the value they've started paying you
some money for that so you have some
sort of product market fit and the third
step is the scale can I deliver this
value in a consistent manner across
large set of users in a reliable manner
so that's the scale part so let's kind
of break it down go one step at a time
the empathy so if you break down the
sales funnel and this is sort of a more
of an abstract breakdown it's every
company have their own little
idiosyncrasies the way they break it
down but in this case let's let's take a
very simple model where hey I have a
bunch of accounts I have to go after the
first thing is which one do I pick are
most likely to buy right this is a very
simple propensity some companies are
very likely to buy and some are not can
I make a list can I have a ranked list
that's a grid and that itself is
actually a bunch of companies are trying
to solve that exact problem once I've
identified my key set of companies I'm
going to go after who do I connect
with and some of these companies are
large there are a lot of decision makers
they're spread spread across different
organizations who are the right people
that I should go after there's another
problem engage let's say I did reach out
to somebody and that happens to be the
right person what kind of content do I
use to engage because I'm sure if you're
on LinkedIn you you see lots of emails
and lot of emails coming from various
people trying to sell you right
you don't necessarily engage with those
interactions but the content is skiing
so you need to deliver the right content
to be able to create that engagement and
so on you acquire a customer and finally
once you've got the customer can this
sell more or can you sell more that's
the upset so that sort of a funnel we
are looking at will not be able to solve
all of it we have to narrow down we
can't boil the ocean so let's pick one
specific problem just the upsell and the
problem statement there is I'm
responsible for about 100 accounts and
out of this some of them are likely to
upsell some of them are not some of them
may be attrition risk and I may lose
that revenue which ones do I pick so the
first question for us is again that's
too broad what is the specific problem
statement and we can break it down or an
average relationship manager and this is
kind of putting ourselves in the shoe of
the the actual users of your product
right and say hey I have identified two
problems first one is they deal with
lots of different systems lot of silos
that a lot of context switches and
that's efficiency loss but then we say
hey is it really a data product maybe
somebody else can solve it maybe it's a
workflow optimization product maybe it's
not in our key area of expertise so
maybe you pass on that maybe another
opportunity or problem statement is
because of lack of creating us
consistent story you're not able to
create meaningful narratives with your
clients or customers and as a result of
that you're leaving dollars on the table
that may be interesting that is maybe
you can drive some interesting data
insights or that specific problem and
and have some wins there so let's zoom
into that
first step again as a product manager so
you know who your who your users are you
sort of identified the opportunity it's
a meaningful opportunity the next step
is do I have an hypothesis right what
can I do differently that others are not
what are my true first principles in
terms of building this this this this
product and you can get a it's it's
pretty intuitive you can think about
here my account is in a growing industry
maybe they'll sell more to because the
whole industry is growing you can look
at is that company itself is growing if
the company is growing maybe they'll buy
more licenses from you the third thing
is if I look at the existing usage of my
product are they close to the ceiling
are they commanded person utilizing my
my my licenses or do I have some stack
so you could use lot of this different
signals and create a hypothesis that hey
if this things happen then I do have an
apostate you to upsell so that's our
first step and then you further break it
down into different types of data some
of this data could be publicly available
so for example whether the industry is
growing there are tons of industries
research papers out there which you can
rely on company websites press releases
you could leverage some of those in
those information that itself is not
enough most of the times you have to
look at your own product usage as well
so again like I said are people engaging
are my users engaging if it's a source
product are they searching how well we
are delivering the value with the
existing footprint that we have with
with the company so based on that you
could you could build a simple rule
based model or you could use data
science and build more kind of
sophisticated machine learn model but
doesn't matter as long as there is a
hypothesis there are certain things you
believe in and you build some sort of
model on top of that you have a ranking
now if you have a way to figure out out
of 100 and accounts that I have which
one goes on top which one goes below and
you can it's not just an model would
give you maybe zero to one score but you
can kind of also create a narrative
around it which which is one is
extremely likely but may not be super
interesting and we'll get into some of
those details so hey now if you have a
model
you've got your UX guy or your UI UI
engineers and you build a simple UI on
top of that you have a product you have
an MVP now and based on a very simple UI
here is here there are three accounts
there I got some information from
publicly available sources like the
information about IBM or Hewlett Packard
and so on I superimpose my scores and at
this point the idea is hey I give you
the score and mr. rep you would be able
to act be able to act on it great first
product great MVP but then you hit the
user and this is this is typically what
we see as we can have all the product so
users would see you would do your user
research and put this in front of
different reps and they would say hey I
kind of get it right I know what problem
you are trying to solve
I can I can understand that this is a
real problem I get that but I don't
trust it I have been selling for 20
years and you are telling me some stupid
score is going to tell me what I should
do right that's that's a first of all
you hit into and this is real so that
you are fighting against the behaviors
that are ingrained in the way people do
their their work and you have to now
change that that behavior and what's the
right way to do that so they would like
to know what the score is what does it
mean for me what actions I can take so
you now and the result of net result of
that is if you're a product manager
you've got a big bump when you rolled
out your product you got a big bump a
lot of people are using it and then down
because you're not delivering the key
value in a right manner so let's go
solve so the key to getting engagement
is to be transparent
say it's not and this is one of the key
takeaways it's not just enough to say
hey here is my score my big
sophisticated machine learning score
gave me this specific number and based
on that we rank you need to tell them
how does it relate to them you need to
speak the language of your users in
terms of the sales you could say hey
here is an opportunity
it's an upsell opportunity but it's a
relationship building opportunity or
there is new dollars on the table
whatever that is but it has to be in a
manner where sales reps get it once you
have their attention because the dollar
speaks once you have their attention now
you go into details what are the signals
I'm using or what are the signals that
the the machine learn model is using to
come up with that recommendation why
those signals matter because again
they'd have every rep or every user have
their own hypothesis in terms of what
works and what doesn't work so you are
trying to get that trust built with this
with this users why the signals matters
and the last step which is probably the
most important one is what's the action
you can take with it without that action
it's incomplete
you could have a really nice prediction
really highly accuracy but if you're not
able to drive specific actions it's
almost useless so you need to close that
loop it needs to end and the other
benefit of that action is now you can
track now you can actually track user
behaviors and feed get that feedback
back into your machine learning
algorithm or whatever model that is and
and improve and that's super useful and
think about serendipity part I'll
address that again but I just wanted to
plant that seed why it's why it's
important and we'll talk about that
again in the summary slide alright so
you can move from the the initial
hypothesis you deliver the product which
works and users are engaging with it the
third step is again back to the trust
and I really wanted to make sure Trust
is really kind of communicated here
in any of the data products that I
worked with that trust always becomes a
key area to look at in a systematic
manner and how does that trust get built
it wouldn't get built overnight but the
transparency is the key so for example
in in the sales intelligence product we
show number of matrix and data points
all over the place it's not just the
recommendations that you saw but things
like hey what's the size of my book of
business or how much quota have attained
all these data points are need to be
aligned with thee let's say timestamps
when things were refreshed where did
this data come from so more of this
transparency that you can bring into
data do the user more trust you would
build over a period of time and this
will also give you again interesting
feedback if your recommendations are
wrong for some reason because the data
refresh didn't happen at the right time
the job failed for some reason now reps
are not trusting they are not doubting
your leg or them now they are doubting
the data refresh time stem and now they
are telling you that hey I in I know
you're giving me these recommendations
but it's because the data didn't get
refresh and now you have an opportunity
to clean it up so so so the the
transparency helps immensely and the
third one is always have your user
experience collect feedback
obviously it's part of the product you
have to track every action that the user
takes in they in the in the portal but
at the same time try to make it explicit
as well maybe in app surveys that's a
great way to collect feedbacks
periodically so I guess I talked ahead
of the slide but in a nutshell so these
are some of the ideas I talked about
which is the transparency and so on in
actual actual UI personalization happens
kind of helps immensely as well so if
you're if if you are giving a very
specific recommendation by saying that
hey mr. rep I understand your book of
business
I understand which business you're part
of if you're a multi line of business
organization
or I understand what your role is and
based on that I'm giving you a very
specific recommendation that's that's
relevant to you that creates trust so
some of the ideas there but essentially
building that trust is there is the
critical part and and that brings us to
what we have it Medicaid LinkedIn in
terms of sales intelligence we call it
NBA next best action and essentially the
goal of that is exactly what I described
which is deliver real-time personalized
actionable intelligence to move sales
opportunities forward and the goal is
for our sales reps to our sales force to
be post data-driven in the industry and
ensure that we are enabling them to sell
more things faster that's that's that's
our Charter all these ideas have come
together we have been working on on them
for for many quarters now for one of the
business lines we have rolled this out
and we are getting some very interesting
field feedback so it's a it's a real
product at this point it's a gdpr
compliant in there in the world that we
live in it so it's a big liability if we
don't if we don't have that covered so
compliance is a big area of focus as
well and and from a tracking perspective
it's a daily active users case we almost
want this to be reps go to place every
morning and act on the idea
commendations that we are providing to
them so so that's sort of what we have
built takeaways
so and essentially the product basic
product principle still hold so just
because it's a data product doesn't mean
there are some different set of
principles that kick in you still have
to make sure you're reading the right
stuff this is the strategy part again
you still have to make sure that your
bidding stuff in a right manner and this
is there this is the usability part I
trade right measure a nitrate that's
always critical you'll never get it
right in the first go-around and so from
from that perspective make sure every
interaction that you care about is
tracked and not just track but then
correlate it back to the value levers
that you're delivering and that gives
you an analytical framework in terms of
if I have 15 new features I have
implement which one really matters which
one moves the needle so that analytical
framework could be super important as
you kind of evolve the product this
second point again I think it kind of
keeps coming back we we oftentimes get
into the the sophisticated machine
learning algorithms or models too for
the recommendation system it's a great
end state but doesn't have to be the
first step and in fact and this is the
journey we went through our first
version was entirely rule-based
and that allowed us to still deliver
value still deras the product still
makes sure that the first two steps in
the journey that we had adequately
address user pain points and understood
their behaviors and that helped us the
when the machine learning model kicked
in we were in a much better position
from the feature engineering perspective
because we understood what what features
mattered so so from a version one
daughter perspective go build rule-based
system it's perfectly okay it's a
quickest way to get out there and
collect feedback and eventually you can
evolve into a more sophisticated model
and the last one is again Trust is the
key for data products particularly data
can do funny things at different times
and if you don't have that trust any
disconnect can can break that trust so
so focus focus on that and ahead so let
me just I'm sure this is some
think I stumbled upon and this is kind
of highly philosophical but but if you
replace life with data products it's
kind of a same thing you would learn a
lot you'll you'll learn a lot but
looking back you you have to really go
through that journey feel few times get
your lessons and hopefully you'll
they'll make sense to you and next time
around you'll be in a better position to
do to solve the opportunity that you
have in front of you so that's our talk
happy to answer questions I'm ahead of
time Wow
curious if you did any experimentation
to kind of measure the results or the
efficacy of your tools yeah so so we
sort of break down the whole measurement
part into two big buckets the first one
is just a product bucket where we
measure the actual usage so weekly
actives daily actives click-through
rates on recommendations we explicitly
give thumb up thumb down so we measure
that but that is all in product behavior
and that does not necessarily commune
communicate whether you deliver the
value did you actually move the equation
I was talking about so that's what we
considered the value bucket and for the
value bucket we work very closely with
our sales ops organizations where they
have instrumented ways to measure how
opportunities are mood in Salesforce for
example and and there is some a/b
testing is kind of a for the data sets
that we available is not as much data as
we would like but some sort of testing
to make sure that this correlates to
that
so if increase CTR by 5% for example
that translates into X dollars in
influence revenue from other product so
we do some of that measurement
do you have any issues with bias being
fed into the model during retraining in
that the account executives or account
managers are seeing high scores so
they're biased towards that potentially
being a better deal and putting more
effort into it and then using the data
that's based on that to retrain it later
is that a bad thing though potentially I
mean if if it's highlighting the wrong
deals and they're trying harder yeah
good good questions I don't think we
have systematically look at that but I
think that's a good I mentioned
serendipity and and I didn't address
that so there's a great way to address
that so the serendipity is exactly what
you're talking about which is reps
expect something and and they have their
own mental models as well and if from
model perspective if you're always
giving them top five ranked
recommendations which are exactly aligns
with what reps mental model is there is
no surprise it's like yeah what's new
right so so bringing that novelty factor
bringing that serendipity is important
and from a machine learn model we look
at like hundreds of different features
so sometimes even though the recommend
the the score is not the top not
extremely likely we might want to mix
things up and and bring something which
is not highly likely to close but still
surface those recommendations because
that novelty sometimes matter and that
has some aha moment associated with oh I
didn't know this and if we can somehow
elicit that aha moment that I would have
missed this opportunity that's the hook
and those are those serendipitous
scenarios that we want to highlight as
much as we can I actually have a
question building off of that like how
do you promote that serendipity and that
aha moment imbalance against the need
for trust that you discussed in your
talk by by collecting feedback so again
every recommendation that we give bead
through the novelty side of it or be it
very highly deterministic score based we
are always asking what number come down
and in fact for some of the
recommendations we give the the the the
rate that we see is like 60 to 70% thumb
bubble I don't know it's not thumb up
its accepts which means that I like this
recommendation not necessarily I will
act on it but but it looks relevant so
and that can be attributed back to
whether it was a serendipity one or was
it a hardcore score one and we can go
back in and balance that we have time
for a few more questions if there are
any if not I have one more question so I
was wondering how as a product manager
working on the heavily data-driven
product how do you balance your time and
your team's roadmap on things related to
like the UI that the salespeople see
versus improving the machine learning
model and the data behind it versus
selling your product to the different
lines of business yeah I saw and as you
know it's it's a it's a complex
ecosystem so obviously we work with
engineering data science design insight
filth insights and obviously reps are
over our our customers from product
manager perspective I think it's all
prioritization and and and
prioritization within the context of a
product lifecycle so in the early phases
where new things are getting developed
it's it's more about the risking the
value of the product itself so in that
phase we focus a lot more on getting the
design right so a lot of early
interactions with a designer the user
studies user interviews and making sure
whatever we are building is the right
stuff in parallel and data science teams
might look at some of these problem
statements and start hypothesizing what
might be a good way to to address some
of the problems we are trying to solve
but at least from purely from product
manager perspective I don't worry about
that at all in the early phases once we
have Dearest
product once it's out there words
version one dot R is out there we have
solved for engagement because that's key
we have solved for click-through rates
and the quality of the initial
recommendations then more of our models
are optimizations on top of that and and
that's how kind of time gets assigned in
a different parts of the product
lifecycle
[Music]